look at Canada look at what you can do
in Canada now in the name of compassion
look at the Canadian government's
websites the way in which it presents
next march as being this wonderful new
opportunity for Canadians this really is
something atrocious happening in our own
time and as the editor of spectator
phrase and Allison has said to me a
number of times and I often quote it
instead of just wrecking through the
past and looking at what other people
did and how astonishingly awful it was
also think of what is happening in your
own time that our successors might think
is equally awful and look at in an
equally despising light try to work out
what they are now and try to stop them
early I would suggest that when it comes
to medically assisted dying in the west
and the slippery slope in these Ultra
liberal democracies it is just such a
case